Jesse Palmer joins us how did it feel
last night Jess for a lot of different
people you know associated with the NFL
and with the ESPN and with ABC and all
of us but you know I really thought
everyone did a great job pulling it off
Rison I'm Maria Taylor Tom Rinaldi we're
all in studio you know here in Bristol
Bristol Connecticut and you know we
obviously had a bunch of analysts in
different places and around but you know
just a great job communicating you know
at the end of the day you know the NFL
Draft for us you know we look we look
forward to this every year we have so
much fun doing this it's still one of
the biggest sporting event you know of
the year certainly in this country and
while I know it was going to look a lot
different last night I think we felt
like we were still able to to tell a lot
of stories and show a lot of the
emotions there were tremendous
interviews with the players with coaches
and with their families via you know via
satellite via remote but I think a lot
of that still came through so you know
we had a lot of fun last night I know
we're really excited to do it again
tonight what was your oh well moment
last night I think for me it was
probably either Isaiah Simmons falling
to the Arizona Cardinals I fully
expected him to be gone bye bye bye the
fourth picks when I thought to going to
the New York Giants and the fact that
Kliff Kingsbury landed him you know I
think at number eight to me was was
tremendous and then I sent Jordan love
going to Green Bay Packers late in the
first round I think was surprising a lot
of people thought they might throw wide
receiver and get Aaron Rodgers some help
and I know that you know the Jordan love
story was all of his talent and
obviously with the 17 interceptions that
was sort of a jekyll-and-hyde scenario
and who was going to take the chance on
him and at the end of the day with Aaron
Rodgers going into his 16th year the
Packers decided to to make the
contingency pick I thought that was
really interesting but you know this you
played the position you were a backup
and understand that role if you're
brought in if you know are you
threatening to the starting quarterback
normally we didn't do that you bring in
a backup and he wasn't gonna threaten
the starter you know Peyton Manning with
his backup for all those years with the
Colts like you never had some
Patriots bring in Garoppolo I don't know
if they thought he was gonna threaten
Tom as quickly as he did but now you
bring in Jordan love extremely talented
and what do you think the time frame is
on Jordan Love developing and how
important is it for him to develop into
the heir apparent for Aaron Rodgers well
alpha quarter tech as we all know and I
don't think he feels threatened at all
personally I think Aaron Rodgers could
play another four years minimum if he
wanted to having said that this is a
great situation for Jordan love and
honestly then I think it's a situation
that he needs he needs to be on the
bench and he needs to watch one of the
great decision-makers in the game today
play football and he needs to see that
Jordan 1 through 17 picks last year when
I watch the tape on him it wasn't an
issue of accuracy it was an issue of
decision-making and oftentimes for
strongarm quarterbacks they believed
they could make each and every single
throw and it gets them in trouble and I
do think at times last year for Jordan
Levitt Utah State he was pressing he
didn't have a lot of help he didn't have
great protection up front you didn't
have wide receivers separating and
getting wide open so I think Jordan
really felt like he had to make
superhuman type plays in order for them
to be competitive in win games but I
think now in a situation like Green Bay
they can help and Aaron Rodgers can show
him and help coach them out of those bad
decisions to understand you don't have
to make every play we've got Davante
Adams we've got a good young tight end
and Jay Stern Berger we've got Aaron
Jones our running back their parts and
pieces around you Aaron Rodgers arguably
has the strongest arm in the National
Football League doesn't throw a lot of
interceptions though because he's very
smart he makes good decisions
Jordan love is going to have to sit and
wait and watch but but I don't think you
could ask for a better situation if you
were George love and if you're Aaron
Rodgers you're not threatened because
you're not losing your job anytime soon
talking to Jesse Palmer ESPN college
football analysts
back on ABC's coverage tonight and
Saturday beginning at noon Eastern
you're so good at this
looking at these quarterbacks and
assessing you know how good they are and
what they need to work on I'm curious
how tough it is though just to take them
from college to the pros
and as they make
transition because I could look at a guy
in college and say he's really good case
in point Patrick mahomes I thought he
was fascinating I had no idea he would
be anywhere near what he is now whereas
deshaun Watson I said that guy's a star
how do you try to troubleshoot this and
say this guy will work or this guy won't
you know I think evaluating the
quarterback position to me is probably
the hardest evaluation of any single
individual position I think in all of
sports
I just think Dan there are so many
different variables and factors that go
into it both physical and mental and
emotional you know if you said of the
quarterbacks that got picked last night
who am i least concerned about I would
say probably Joe Burrell out of LSU I've
said this and I'll keep saying it 13
years at ESPN he's the most accurate
quarterback that I've seen in college
football and I think accuracy is
something that you can improve with
fundamentals but ultimately I think it's
inherent and Joe burrow completing 76%
of his throws and in offense where they
throw the ball deep down the field just
constantly hitting receivers in the
numbers and in the facemask look I know
that accuracy is going to translate to
the next level regardless of what system
he plays in and then there's a guy like
Justin Herbert out of Oregon that's
playing sort of in this up-tempo spread
offense there's sort of a lot of dinking
and dunking a lot of screen throws and
pumps taking guys early to open up more
throws downfield the systemic change for
him with the Los Angeles chargers that's
going to be a whole lot different and I
think certainly Scouts looking at him at
the Senior Bowl and how well he
performed there it gives them hope that
he can make that transition but it's
just simply something we just don't know
so you know it really is in a lot of
ways still a guessing game and there's a
lot of big names still out there that
we're going to see picked coming out
there again whether it's Jacob Eason out
of Washington who played in a pro-style
system or Jalen Hertz that played it in
a more Pro style system and Alabama and
then more of an air-raid system of
Lincoln Riley at Oklahoma how is that
going to translate to the next level as
well be interesting to see all right if
you need a quarterback in this second
round who you takin
I'm going with Jacob Eason you know for
me I love the fact playing at Washington
under center with a tight end and a
fullback on the field you know this guy
had to play you know versus condensed
defenses and looks took a lot of seven
step drops and play-action and he can
push the football downfield six foot six
230 pounds he was the number one
quarterback coming out of high school
for a reason he has a lot of town he
started at Georgia as a true freshman of
course got hurt lost his job to Jake
from and had to sit out two years
between you know sitting out at Georgia
with the injury and then transferring to
Washington and having to redshirt you
know and I think that probably hurt his
development a little bit but I think he
has a lot of the natural tools you need
to succeed at the next level then I'll
say this I think the biggest story
tonight is where does Jalen Hertz go
yeah he reminds me a lot you know a lot
of potentially Taysom Hill with the New
Orleans Saints Jalen Hertz you know he's
an alpha 138 games in college at two
different programs and I think after the
Lamar Jackson phenomenon now everyone's
trying to find that next that that that
x-factor at quarterback that could take
your offense to the next level he's not
as dynamic of runner as Lamar Jackson
certainly but he ran for over thirty
eight hundred yards and forty three
touchdowns in college and he's a guy
who's a quarterback but I couldn't see
Jalen Hurd's playing a little running
back a little receiver a little special
teams at the next level doesn't have to
play quarterback necessarily right away
and with New England and Pittsburgh and
Indianapolis maybe Jacksonville there's
some teams that need quarterbacks early
so Jacob Eason Jalen Hertz I think those
will be two of the bigger storylines I
think at the start of tonight yeah I
hope I hope Hertz gets a chance I like
that kid the way he handled the Alabama
situation goes to Oklahoma approves that
you know he can go into that same system
the Baker Mayfield and Kyler Murray did
and and add another dimension to it I I
I would love to see him in a place like
Carolina where he could wait a couple
years for Teddy Bridgewater and then
maybe you ease him in to the lineup
there but I think there's some
fascinating second-round possibilities
here also is it tougher to handicap an
offensive tackle or a wide receiver in
the first round that's a great question
you know I think
for a very very long time it was it was
tougher to handicap wide receivers I
think based on the system that you play
in it and especially in the college game
today with you know these quote-unquote
air raid offenses where there's empty
sets and you know a lot of these
receivers that they don't have these
extensive route trees that you see on
Sundays in the National Football League
it's either catch a screen catch a
bubble screen make a guy miss go score
or just run a go route and highpoint the
football and score you know but today
it's hard to look at offensive tackles
as well because you know with the same
reason we don't see a lot of I formation
offense anymore in college football and
you don't see a lot of the same run
schemes or pass protection schemes in
college as you do in the National
Football League the good news profit to
tackles today in these types of offenses
in college is that often is more often
but not you're on an island you're not
getting a lot of help from tight ends
and running back so you can see who's a
good pass protector and who's a good
athlete but because of the lack of run
schemes I mean you see a lot of zone
runs and and you know zone reads and
these run pass options but you know
again you don't necessarily see tackles
with the tight end lined up beside the
but now they have to they have to down
block or they have to pull necessarily
or get into the second level I think
it's much tougher today to really get a
good idea at offensive tackle with
respect to the scheme that they're
playing we know who great ass grew the
good athletes are and who can bench
press a lot who can runs 40-yard dash
times very very fast through the combine
and all the testing but you know I think
the way the game has changed
particularly at the college level
sometimes makes it it tougher to grade
out these offensive lineman's and help
predict how successful they're going to
be on some day last hour we broke the
story that Chris Simms the former NFL
quarterback he was first approached in
the same offseason as you to be on The
Bachelor he believes he was approached
first and he said no he couldn't because
Jon Gruden he said would kill him if he
did does that bother you as a
quarterback or as just
handsome guy that Christians might have
been approached before you to be on the
bathroom well I mean ultimately you know
it makes me feel like sloppy seconds for
ABC first and foremost seem shaken you
seem shaken by this room no I mean yeah
I might I might you know I'm gonna I'm
gonna make a few phone calls okay I
might have to I might have to sit out
the second round tonight just try to get
over that before I could recover for the
third round I mean not only am i jealous
that Chris Sims was a lefty and
controlled tremendous velocity but now
on top of that just come to realize I
was I was you know set playing second
fiddle to ABC all along in that process
you know 14 years after it's happened at
least I guess I get some clarity and
some finality after this whole but see
this is ABC they bring us The Bachelor
right and you're working for ABC tonight
I mean you gotta have mixed emotions
about this dress yeah you know and it's
just you know I'm trying to wear
different hats here yeah offer the same
network but at some point you can't you
can only juggle so much you know prayers
thoughts and prayers for you tonight
we're here for you if you need us and
good luck that's Jesse Palmer yes being
college football analyst